hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody's favorite
new podcast this is are you garbage
it's a show where we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day we're back here aunt
toddy's basement sure
the bed bugs are gone yeah yeah i want
everybody to know that the bed bugs are
gone fleas are back
what i heard from mary jo finnery all
right over at the deli was that one when
we were away
toddy saw a lazy boy out on the street
paid the ups guy 20 bucks to bring it in
turns out it was infested
it was lousy with bed bugs so we had to
shut the joint down for a little bit
get the place bombed but i found out
cody resold it
on facebook marketplace so we covered
the the bombing right there
it's good to be hearing about this for
the first time after i sat on some
cushions
[Laughter]
these have a real [ __ ] letterman vibe
to him i can't tell if you're [ __ ]
around or what
and then she resold it on facebook
marketplace
now it's somewhere out in long island we
just keep following the chair
we haven't been here in a while it's fun
to do this my co-host is coming at you
rudely right next to me yeah no not rude
jesus christ every time foley leans on
the table
oh my god i got to put i got to put
steel legs on this thing
i got the giggles of me today too ever
since ribs
ever since ribs dude i've been having
the chuckles ribs went over the
starboard side get her
like jacking sick i'm like is this my
nicotine lozenge or is the table shaking
so much from
fully storytelling get some [ __ ] get
some of these people have
pointed it out big guys laughing
anyhoo excuse me for breaking the fourth
wall there folks my co-host is coming at
you
from right next to me he is the ceo of
ru garbage
really uh he turned the podcast into a
global conglomerate
okay kevin james ryan everybody still no
cards have been shipped out stop [ __ ]
emailing me
uh guys all the cards are going out this
week what's up thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available
on youtube those numbers are true to
[ __ ] roof baby
get involved and then also i mean you
know it i know it t-bone knows it
ru garbage where it all happens you can
sign up you get uh
bonus episodes at ayg you get episodes
of hard feelings which is me and foley
behind the curtains
hard what hard feelings oh we got them
you want them you love it we know it
10 members do it it's the [ __ ] hit of
the year i didn't know that but i
thought that was gonna be a fun this is
the longest intro that we've gotta
use car commercial every time fully talk
if you don't act now
uh patreon.com and then uh with the top
tier
people we play are you garbage with you
guys once a month sign up it's a
good time all right and of course a
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the pride of the chicago comedy
t-bone mcmuffin mcmullen toby mcmullen
everybody
ah there you go you're off oh good yeah
i got foley's broken cable that he
destroyed
this big [ __ ] sausage finger yeah
damn him
he bones out um t-bones popping and
crackling over there
i am when we first started we were using
handheld before like we didn't have any
money for [ __ ] nine dollar stands
yeah yeah so we were using handheld mics
and fully's just so [ __ ] high strung
yeah that
he was going through a brand new cable
every week
chewing through it right through it he
ran out of the nicotine
i'd look over he'd have it wrapped
around his hand like he's a [ __ ]
gladiator
i'm like he's [ __ ] pounding the table
i had a whole thing about these nice dms
i've been getting people asking if i
have the flagrant flu or if i got the
covid
yeah yeah yeah no you know
i'm afraid to talk into this thing now
yeah you're good just don't touch it
you'll be fine
any bad jokes blame it on the cable yeah
we love you buddy
yeah thanks guys gang this is a family
episode if you couldn't tell by now
uh we have a previous guest on an old
friend of ours we got a little company
in here
we started from [ __ ] jump street yeah
in the village you were just reminiscing
about it
i think on your episode we said you were
classy
i think no she was trash but then you
came in with the sleeve tattoo
yeah yeah first of all it's not totally
a sleeve
it's not totally it's infected it looks
like sailor jared it might be infected
which uh which does it is a little
trashy look at that old ma
right there look at that thing might as
well be an anchor
it sprawls rough around the edges damn
you got some [ __ ] pipes on you too
though
we'll show those germans won't we yeah
it is [ __ ] it's very red right now i
mean my uh uh
would you get that on the way in i got
it yesterday got that in the sheets
i got this less than 12 hours ago jesus
christ also i think
i think it's the perfect explanation of
rosebud
is to take off a nice cardigan sweater
and then show her brand new sleeve
tattoo
this isn't you're trash this isn't a
sleeve i just have small arms
you haven't got a collared shirt i can
tell you that this is uh this is what
they call a panel
panel i found that so what is it it's a
rat in a flower what is it yeah it's a
rat and a flower holding a flower
that's you again you're a rat and a
flower that's right something that's
right some guys
pretty but tough and they were like and
then she goes well what about a little
mouse knitting and i was like i don't
want knitting on there
i don't want anybody knitting on my arm
sure and she said well what if we just
put a mouse in a flower and i said that
that works
i did let her pick it i didn't so it's a
mouse or a rat
it's a mouse it'd be cool if it was a
rat it wouldn't eaten pizza would it
that's disgusting yeah that's not you
don't want it it's [ __ ] revolting
um is that your first tattoo this is my
no this is my first real one
you know what i mean the first one where
i'm like i feel it in my arm what are
the other ones
jailhouse you have like a heart i have
like
i have like a a little feather here i
have the word pow
behind my ear that was my first one
p-a-l p-a-l-p-p-o-w
not prisoner of war just pow like pal
yeah that was like that was just a mood
i was in i i was i didn't know what i
i've never picked a tattoo before i
walked in to get it including this
that's the way to go i think yeah
listen i think that's uh that is the way
to go because
i feel like people get these tattoos
they're all meaningful and then they
want to [ __ ] describe to you what it
means and it's like i don't need a
kind of story but that's like getting
their getting a haircut off the haircut
wall yeah they're giving you
give me the number 18. give me the 18.
yeah that's so what's wrong with that
and then are these little well is that
pen yeah no these are actually
that's real tattoo this is a real tattoo
but it was just somebody came to a party
somebody came to a party with a tattoo
gun and i just let him practice on me so
i probably have hepatitis
this kid's screwball that's jesus this
girl's broncos
dang this is our incredibly special
guest that we have here with today we
didn't even introduce her that's
that's the kind of fire we're getting
off to here back at [ __ ] tooties
but let's talk real quick she is the
co-host with her
main squeeze andy haynes of find your
beach the amazing podcast
and she's going to be recording her
debut album in zany's nashville
march 14th ladies and gentlemen arnold
pal from the beltway to broadway to
hollywood baby
rosebud baker yeah ribs baker thanks
happy to be here coming in
really seriously does this look infected
to you
how the [ __ ] would everything looks
infected yeah that's true
this looks like your neck i have a thing
that's like a pimple
it's not a pimple i can't get at it
crazy well we assumed you couldn't get
out of it
he's like for some reason i can't reach
around my own body
[ __ ] what'd you say bad cable kenny
what do you got to say
[Laughter]
you gave him that mic on purpose
we had to yeah we took my cables because
we had to operate remote last week
during the bed bugs yeah keep the
storyline going i hope that's not
[ __ ] real i really can't tell
okay we're in a high-rise building right
now we're on the we're in the basement
but still
yeah we got a trash can we got wet wipes
we got the whole smear here
yeah you know how trash cans and wet
wipes make you classy
hey that was about 22 bucks i'm not
gonna lie that'll be coming out of the
the tally at the end of the month yeah
it will yeah so are the seat cushions
eighteen dollars i spent amazon he
doesn't like them
nobody likes rosebud didn't like him
t-bone didn't like him
i really don't know how you're
comfortable sitting on them i don't
because they were too small for my butt
it's the same her butt could fit inside
your butt it feels like you're just
my butt would be as big as this cushion
is
under yours yeah it's not that it's just
these old hardwood
uh chairs
i'm on heart medication the old hard
chairs they hurt my butt after doing two
episodes
oh yeah okay so i like the cushioning
that's good i mean it's good to
get your needs met thank you yeah
there's a lot of ford yeah he's a big
guy
you know we gotta we gotta work around
it a little bit i'm a big guy
a big guy with a big heart and we're
here on a big podcast
[ __ ] screw balls this week thank you
for coming in
it's also for this is the first time
we've seen each other in like
probably maybe the longest ever since no
i mean we've
been waiting no more than that i think
two weeks two weeks maybe
um so we get a little we get a little
squirrely too
it's like two little school girls when
we get together yeah i see him a couple
times a week i hate him
yeah then i don't see him and i'm like
ah this guy's gonna miss my brother yeah
yeah um but that being said it's a
family episode
let's get into some of the [ __ ]
patreons questions baby so when you sign
up for patreon we will answer your
garbage question
it's just the best way to do it um right
before this we were talking
these two dirt balls how to pop their
[ __ ] nicotine lozenges and
nicorette gum that's what i'm dealing
with meanwhile i'm outside
i'm still smoking the last man i can't
believe what happened you
i can't believe what you told me
actually happened what that i
the nicotine gun yes i've overdosed on
nicotine multiple gums
several times multiple times that's one
of the trashiest things i've ever heard
in my life
i've done it and i'm wearing basketball
i did it with my husband together as one
we we both did it at the same time he
smoked or did he
we both were vaping i was like how i
fell in love we both like you know we
screwed for the first time rolled over
and both took a hit off our jewels and i
was like we are
soul mates i can't see him vaping oh
yeah candy haynes very funny comedian
yeah we're both recovering
drug addicts so you know oh he is yeah
yeah that's like that's like the [ __ ]
attic starter kit yeah coffee and six
you get a jewel
a coffee um a tattoo
and a church basement and you got
yourself the
the attic starter pack right there uh
yeah that being said this is a perfect
lead in uh this is from
andrew uh or andre i don't know you know
your name's kind of [ __ ] up have you
ever smoked
it's a-n-d-r-e-j that's on
did he misspell his own name i don't
know he's just racist
andre andre andridge andridge
whatever you got a screwball first name
hey either way we love you buddy
uh have you ever smoked a cigarette
while ordering at a drive-through cause
that is a
top ten dirt peg yeah they're fake it's
a real dirt bike absolutely
really yeah oh rosebud you're a [ __ ]
animal smoking a pot
seriously and you got the cigarette in
the hand going out the window to get to
to get the burgers
yeah you hand them the cash yeah so the
cigarette's going in there
do you want some sauce i'm like i'm not
even gonna taste it
all my taste buds are squished
[Laughter]
i'm just doing this for the rebates i've
definitely done that yeah oh
man for sure that's garbage
i don't think i i don't think i have
i've always tried to be very considerate
with my smoking even now i started back
up like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um i go like away from like my apartment
build like i try to go
i'll encounter the least amount of
people you're good with that i'll say
that i'm like i'll go stand
kind of in the street between these two
cars yeah yeah and
but you i've seen you smoke and it
always has this very lonely vibe to it
yeah i'm always like doing wonders for
your social life buddy
you do smoke like kenny rogers yeah i
get after them quick
he looks like he's like on a bounty
mission every time he [ __ ]
lights one up gotta close the
this guy's case by memories yes yes
a hundred percent i just got a thousand
mile stare just yeah
going i'm gonna go outside and relive
the past for ten minutes right tough man
it's
as i started smoking again i like i like
really [ __ ]
hate it down to the point now where i'm
like three drags and then i flick it i'm
like what am i even the worst
yeah yeah for sure that's how it that's
but that's just that's the cycle of
smoking that's the whole thing
i know that's half the experience of
enjoying a cigarette is
wondering why you're here yeah yeah yeah
i'm also like
but there are some that are [ __ ] oh
yeah man
one after like you gotta earn who you're
recovering but one after the first one
after like two or three drinks is the
best [ __ ] birthday you can get hands
down
absolutely food drinks and you step
outside on like an autumn night
yeah i get it you can hear it crackling
yeah you're like and it burns you get it
you have that burning sensation in your
throat and you're like this is why i
came here
this is what we play for baby yeah i
love it that's trash my my mom has
definitely done that before yeah your
mom
your mom smokes in the sense that like
you're my
like it's like cartoon like she is the
definition of like an
80s smoker you think you know yeah just
like hey henry
she's like tiny little hey you know the
opposite of him i remember
you mean my future yeah yeah i rose
about in 20 years yeah i remember being
in
our jeep we had like a old wooden panel
jeep and it was like the 80s
no seat belts if it was it was a little
button one remember it was like
30 degrees outside or like 30 it was
cold right
and the windows rolled up the [ __ ]
heat on and just
yeah crushing them just sitting there i
missed that i missed those days when
cars wouldn't tell you to save your own
life you know oh yeah
they would have been exactly or whatever
[ __ ] obnoxious i mean how do you know
i'm not
suicidal doesn't shut up i'm rolling the
dice over here right
every once in a while if you're just
zipping around the neighborhood it's
nice to have the seat belt off
yeah yeah i'm not a big i'm kidding you
kids keep your seatbelt
don't use drugs
his uh opinions are no way connected to
uh are you garbage incorporated
um all right this one's from this will
be more this is out of my realm a little
bit because it's uh has anyone in your
family ever pierced their infant child's
ears
or how old were you when you got yours i
definitely have cousins that have
pierced their infant child ears
yeah i've seen it at the mall it does
not look fun for anybody involved the
kid freaks out yeah the kid screams
right away
i've seen videos of of kids i don't know
why i've watched videos like this
but i've seen videos of kids dark web
getting their ears pierced
and they're and they just seem like
really chill about it really
yeah it's pretty cute when you see it
when you see it and they're just like
what wow something hurt for a second and
they don't really like
you know as long as you're like laughing
at a kid oh really yeah but i don't
i mean i've never i don't know shout out
to the shamany mall i've seen [ __ ]
babies just screaming in the middle
yeah they're just like at the piercing
pagoda or whatever
yeah it's a scene my first couple of
haircuts i screamed i can't imagine
getting my ears pierced
really you were that kid sitting there
in the [ __ ] fire truck or whatever
oh my dude i bugged out i don't want
this [ __ ] pose
this guy's got scissors and a mustache
on the [ __ ] [ __ ] trust this guy
he's coming at you with scissors yeah i
didn't like it yeah i don't care how
many lollipops i [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] mm-hmm
i couldn't imagine getting my ears
pierced i would have lost it because
they had this like wooden thing because
you couldn't fit in the seat oh they put
you on the booster yeah
they borrowed it from the tgi fridays
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
silk sheet that goes around you no good
i [ __ ] freaked out have you ever
pierced any of your own
yeah yeah yeah absolutely i tried
i've tried piercing my belly button i've
tried it
yeah i did get my belly button pierced
eventually but it was for one day and it
was because i was in a fight with a
an ex do you realize how crazy that is
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i do realize how crazy that is bear
grylls
were you inside of an elk at the time i
was literally
this guy hated belly button piercing we
got in a fight i was like i know
so go to the mall why would you do this
is brother no no these are two separate
occasions
so the one time that i successfully
pierced it was professionally
i think you told us this i think i did
yeah i think i did i was
like trashier the second time around got
a belly button piercing to piss a guy
off yeah
never mentioned that i pierced my own
though i tried piercing my own for a
while so i sat there with ice
on my belly button for probably seventh
eighth grade just
i was trying to numb myself in a pin
trying to trying to try to do that yeah
and what were you gonna do just leave
the pin in there
yeah no you get a a safety pin and you
leave it in for like
a week establish yeah and then uh
yeah then you can put whatever in three
weeks later you got tetanus and a nice
nice piercing
even attempt it means you have you had
the guts yeah well there's your question
you're crazy enough to really like feel
it go in and
keep going i think i've told her on this
i did my my buddy's eyebrow
in seventh or eighth grade and i got in
but then i couldn't get
through the second layer you weren't
[ __ ] man
you're like i thought i was man enough
i'm like i'll do it [ __ ]
then i felt the tissue i'm like nope you
start bombing yeah no matter how sharp
you think it is man when you can't get
through that other layer of skin
i know that from picking out splinters
you're like that's how you know every
doctor is a
[ __ ] psychopath they got there is
something wrong with them if you can cut
someone open
yeah you're [ __ ] bonkers i remember i
had a couple of uh
cysts taken out and uh i got it done a
couple
it looks like they left sometimes it's
so gross when you say a couple
yeah because it was cat it was so
cavalier so much nastier yeah
they were actually called i got a little
bit of [ __ ] in my pants
it was like anal beads but just cysts
basically
ah man you're gross anyway this surgeon
was so proud of his stitches that he
like brought me out into the hallway to
show
hey tommy get a load of this you gotta
just fat [ __ ] up you're not gonna
believe it huh
i took a couple of assists out of this
fat pasted
like a goddamn pot roast look at this
kid i gave him a curry
i gave him a popsicle i didn't even need
to get put down for him
he was like a baby getting his ears
pieced he was like so proud
oh god that was nice by the way he
brought that back that is a good feeling
though sometimes jamming something like
that in
feels good could you stab someone you
think no
no i feel like you could in like uh
i feel like you lose it even if it's for
like a minute
right you don't you stay pretty [ __ ]
i feel you could be like well things got
out of hand i'm sorry i have no idea i
have blacked out with rage before yeah
that's that's something that's happened
to me so maybe if i was in that state
then yeah possibly i don't yeah i don't
think you could
no you're like what are you on the other
side of the room i'll get you tomorrow
i'm not getting off this couch just a
comb yeah
i don't think i could i don't think i
could stab or shoot anybody yeah
or beat anybody up for that matter
shooting anybody no shooting
anybody for some reason that seems like
you have to think about it like there's
a
because there's a button you have to
press like stabbing somebody it's almost
like
that's just an extension of your arm you
forget the knife's there why would you
have a knife on you that sounds like
plausible deniability if you ask me
she comes from a good family i really
she's laying an alibi course she's
setting up a gone girl right now
i'm gonna get haynes on the phone i
gotta start don't know
i don't even remember going to the
podcast we're all dead this never gets
released
yeah what do you got cooking here yeah
you got setting up i've already set up
the timing of this i'm like i got a
tattoo 12 hours ago
yeah she has she's already she's already
set the parabola we're taking the fall
for
something over she's got the door locked
[Laughter]
anyway gang real quick want to talk
about the good time we're having over
there on the old
stereo app every thursday night at nine
o'clock
uncle hank and kippy are answering your
questions yeah guys it's like a little
bit of an after party live stream you
can uh
use our link to sign up for the app it's
www.stereo.com
kevin ryan or slash h foley we get to
wet our beaks a little bit oh yeah
you sign up you can ask your questions
live we'll answer them live on the air
we get a couple hundred people in there
every week it's a good time
see you there gang all [ __ ] aside oh
yeah
sheath underwear is the [ __ ] is the best
underwear
that you're might not be wearing yeah
and if you're not
get on right now baby of course you do
so why i'm not an [ __ ]
i'm wearing my sheets i love the sheets
baby fantastic if you're not familiar
with sheath underwear
get familiar with it now there's two the
big thing about it it separates your
dick and your balls they got
a pouch for your balls a little pouch
for your little pee pee
you can put your pee pee and balls in
the same pouch separate pouch no pouch
doesn't matter the big thing about it
i didn't know i needed my balls off of
my leg that is a game changer i've been
walking around like an [ __ ] for 34
[ __ ] years
with my balls stuck to my legs and
that's really just where it started if
you notice now you go to the website
they got hats they got t-shirts
they got everything they got stuff for
the ladies out there so get some for
your ladies use promo code garbage go to
sheath underwear dot com
promo code garbage you save 20 percent
and these guys
are huge supporters of comedy podcasts
they're fans of the show
they like they support all comedy
podcasts
they're advertising everywhere get
involved with them go to sheath
underwear dot com promo code garbage
save on your next order now back to the
show
oh my god um this one is just tr i can't
this is from brandon
and you should we should kick you out of
the patreon putting ketchup on tacos
what
yeah if you put ketchup on tacos you're
trash that's the question you put
ketchup on tacos no
no that's that's brandon's question do
you sound like you're just saying an
alibi
now yeah so you're telling me his
question was not him not me but his
question was ketchup
not going for it
[Laughter]
you get on the phone like brandon's a
different person oh i'm sorry this was
from h
schmoly hang on a sec
you've done it
okay he's done it supposed to be friends
here [ __ ] accusations start flying
around
i've seen you in two weeks you've done
it to me let me explain myself
there's little with food that he hasn't
done i put ketchup on things that maybe
shouldn't get ketchup
but i don't see listen if it's ground
beef it can take ketchup
my god that's it you are a pregnant
woman in her third trimester why not i'm
listen i'm not saying that i would order
it but
it's different countries man it's
different cuisines here
well what is ketchup what is not for
tacos that's what it's for ketchup is
really just sausage
you know what it is it's an italian
condiment yes
well it's actually it's an american it's
an american but with italian roots right
his grandfather came over rachel ray
over here trying to drop knowledge
man you turned tail on that quick it's
an italian
the way she said it i signed right up
i'm like it is i'm great at bullshitting
something i don't
sound like bobby flay yeah you and i
have that in common
what you and i can [ __ ] some [ __ ]
that we don't know and make it sound
like we know what we're talking about
for like a second he doesn't know
anything that's going on with anything
so no but i've heard
holy [ __ ] i've heard foley [ __ ]
where i've i've seen people around him
nodding like he's right and just been
like
absolutely not he has no idea what he's
doing most of the time
he's also funny quiet you cause we we
all started working together and then
as toby learned more about foley he's
just been like
at one point i looked over and he was
pulling his head it was a cartoon
it's always like so what do you mean the
cam he said what do you mean how do you
what questions you ask
how have you made it that far and you're
asking that question now it's crazy ah
that's great what's the problem with it
i could see
it's trash that's trash there's a sauce
for it already they have multiple sauces
the green sauce the red sauce salsa
hold on you have the seasoned meat okay
then you have a
taco shell you put some cheddar cheese
some lettuce tomato
all things that would that could have
ketchup on it
why do you need ketchup that's that yeah
the fact that it's like you're trying to
sour cream
oh no you want a thousand island
dressing on your [ __ ] taco
why wouldn't i yeah that's disgusting
but that's not a thousand dollar
dressing technically
you are a thousand pound man
i was trying to say it when she said
thousand island dressing and then it
came back around after you
i mean timing's key to these things ribs
tried to keep it in the air for a minute
but then she walked away from it
everybody's got the guns pointed at each
other nobody wants to give anybody
anything
he just gave him a point
yeah it's when you're laughing but you
know you don't mean it and so you
immediately try to put it
on it um i don't think t-bone just said
ketchup is british
so you're going british and
mexican they don't mix that don't mix
no in 2020 they do my friend no
i love you kev love all people man
i'm all for globalism but not no that's
not putting ketchup
i'm all for globalism but i put my foot
down
and that's i like different things on on
on i like
weird things on different things no you
like whatever's in the fridge on your
taco
you want to have as much as possible on
your thing you're very it's gluttonous
that's what it is sure yeah it's a sad
meal yeah
uh you shouldn't do that is it that is
that's worse than having it out at
thanksgiving
yeah i mean tacos can go it's a thin
line with tacos you know
like tacos are the only food that can go
from happy to sad depending on the
situation you're eating them in ooh
that's pretty good
you know yeah wow and where you got them
right yeah i do okay at home with me
because when i was a kid our tacos were
sad as [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] garbage time you can
be eating tacos with a bunch of friends
in a restaurant you know you're having
margaritas you're enjoying
a little remembering
you know and then if you're alone in
your car
it's just if you're parked in a taco
bell parking lot there's a difference
it's a whole different meal
it's not a fiesta you add you add
ketchup to that situation
it's bad yeah especially because you had
to bring your own because taco bell
didn't give it to you yeah
i remember one time when i worked in an
office this guy brought tacos in for
lunch that he had made
not like taco bell he brought tacos that
he had nobody talked to him
you bring in yesterday's ortega with
your soft corn tacos yeah hit the
[ __ ] bricks
yeah i remember it's bothered me forever
i saw a guy with
with a pound of cheese a pound of turkey
and a pound of ham making [ __ ]
sandwiches
on the beach oh i was just like this is
the most insane thing i've ever seen him
i apologize good god he'd been there for
three days
all right sandwiches on the beach can
get a little dicey that mayo after when
that sun's on it for a little bit
yikes yeah yeah hang in there yeah
um i don't know if we did this one this
was from another time do you feed the
seagulls when you go to the beach
[ __ ] yeah i have really i have yeah not
recently but yes i've done that maybe
unforgivable
yeah maybe i'd call the police on you if
you were if you were by my crew
you'd be [ __ ] i think i think i think
she's got drugs or something that's fair
that's fair did you grow up going to the
beach though did you guys was it
did you guys summer we were more of a
camping family you're a camping family
yeah
my dad loved to camp that's the thing as
a little kid you know going to the
jersey shore your whole life
you have that for a second where you're
like i like the seagulls
then they [ __ ] instantly become your
enemies right real
[ __ ] quick and even today yeah
they're worse than ever yeah
oh the seagulls have gotten way worse
now it's the music and the sneakers
dude they're terrible that's so funny
it's so try my mom has a theory because
we go down the shore every day i feel
like they've got every bigger one too
she's like they like orange things so
like if anybody has doritos or something
to
put the cheetos down the birds like it
the birds like it more
they're drawn to the color orange i'm
like mom okay
absolutely and on level insane yeah
she's showing in other groups it's the
the gatorade cast
it's the gatorade that's like when my
dog would [ __ ] freak out at somebody
i'd be like i think it's the color blue
yeah my dog freaks out all the time my
mom makes up different things for it
every single time
yeah get to this into that yeah this is
the thing at this you're just an abused
wife at a certain point you're like
trying to come up with situations
i it's just your clothes it's just your
personality i'm sorry yeah but [ __ ]
seagulls
yeah [ __ ] them seriously absolutely i
dude i love all
horrible birds they're worse than
pigeons yeah i actually
yeah they are pigeons don't really
bother well they're really the pigeons
they're dirty but they don't bother you
i like a pigeon ah
i've had pigeons fly dangerously close
to my [ __ ] face
in new york yeah i had a pigeon [ __ ] on
my nose once
jesus yeah people say that's
good luck not if it's on your nose yeah
save it
i was going to jfl and i was on the
phone trying to change my phone plan
with the
with the operator lady i go ah she goes
what i was like
i need you to stay on the phone with me
for a second a bird just [ __ ] on my face
well good news it's your lucky day we
can upgrade you for only 9.99 a month
i go is that good luck she goes not if
it's on your face
next question that's funny um this is
from ivan growing up did you ever spit
on one of your siblings during a fight
because i've been spit on a bunch my
brother was ruthless at times
that's a good question i shh probably
but not
you know it wasn't like a call yeah it
was like you know what i mean i wasn't
like gathering up um
mucus or anything yeah but we it was all
it was all girls
in my family so spitting wasn't yeah but
i feel like you're all kind of spunky
a bit i feel like you're all little
bananas yeah we are absolutely
more is more of a girl's thing in fights
when i pay him for this
[Laughter]
no i think it was more of like a kicking
lying on your back and kicking air pull
oh yeah that was
big yeah
on their backs kicking yeah like a
[ __ ] pig that couldn't turn over
trying to catch your breath yeah my
brother held me down one time
uh he would do like the knees on the
shoulders right which is like
an unforgivable move looking brutal
being on the opposite end of that so
much i could never do it to somebody
because it's so frustrating and so
demeaning yeah
and he held my head down and spit in my
ear dude and
i i still feel it like i still feel it
in my ear and it still gets me mad
wow because i think i wet willied him
and he was like oh yeah
and just pulled my ear he just pisses on
your face
she paid him for that too
no i can't come without it
oh man uh this is from ryan hodges have
you did your family used to reuse
birthday candles
wash them off and then reuse them yeah
no no
never did really yeah really why did you
say that so sternly they're a nickel
or like a hundred of them you know for a
fact your mom never did that
yeah come on i know because my mom
she she was constantly throwing [ __ ]
away my mom's big thing was like walking
through the house
if she couldn't identify an object or
who it belonged to it would go in the
trash yeah i love that mentality
get it the [ __ ] out you can buy a new
one yeah throw it throw it out you sure
related to candles though i'm positive
buddy
it's pretty classy that's the difference
between you two you're a
reusable candle i'm surprised you didn't
you open up your junk drawer there's
like a four
and nine oh zero half all half melted in
there
we'll reuse it you're like 49 only a
couple more years
you're calling up you're calling up your
aunt hey trish can you bring over a six
it's it's tommy's 16th birthday i got
the one we just need the six you got a
six you're getting two birthdays out of
it six and nine
flipping around you're making your cakes
vintage to try to match the candles
there's a blue wanna you know the
seven's yellow yeah totally there was
there was a ziploc bag that had that had
all the candles in there
burnt ones that's poor person mentality
well you know what you know what's even
more trash here we had the candle holder
remember the little flower
yeah those things were real shitty yeah
we had that too
remember those did uh were you guys ever
big on like the re what are the
the ones that wouldn't go out the like
ones
like someone did that once at a birthday
party for a cousin and everybody was
like you
we don't do that you know what i mean
well it's disgusting i mean you're just
spitting on the cake that's the gender
reveal party of the 80s
it really is the trick it really is yeah
now we don't do that over here we don't
do the trick candles
you know what that made me think of i
don't know why the candle holders did
you guys have the little
the corn things that went into the ears
of corn yes
yes yeah okay someone is just fine
someone i know again i don't know
who it was someone asked is that garbage
i think that's what's the class
what's the trashiest way to eat corn on
the cob that's the that was somebody's
question i don't know i know the
questions here's the thing i think when
those came out
it was the classy way to do it and then
they went from classy to trashy in like
a year
yeah because they were like they were
like cheap and they were yeah they were
little corn pieces of corn yeah and you
just look more like a rat eating it
you know and they didn't work that great
they didn't work they really didn't
what's the classiest way to eat it then
the clip it's a great question
you slice it off no yeah my stepmom used
to do that
nope my dad definitely never kids i used
to [ __ ] love it
i think the classy way to eat corn is
with your hands
i think that's got to be the classy just
hold it yeah
like that for sure it's almost like well
what because you know
in this form anybody eating anybody
eating corn with their hands
has not you know their hands are nothing
to be afraid of like anybody that's
afraid to touch
their own food is probably trash that's
pretty genius
that's how you tell the people are clean
mm-hmm he eats corn on the cob with his
hands that guy he washes his [ __ ]
hands i don't know
or i don't i think it's just a trash
food all together
ah i'm not saying it's not good you're
at a barbecue or whatever you grab a
piece yeah of course i don't
have anything in my pocket absolutely
trash food i mean when you talk to trash
food we talk about
corn coffee you talk about corn fed
people you're talking about trash that's
americana summertime
fourth of july
all trash she just [ __ ] called you
out but my sport
my sparkly trash yeah
fourth of july is when we break out the
trashiest dessert of all time
some know it some don't yeah the
friendly's watermelon roll
oh yeah yeah yeah see i don't even know
what that is yeah what they do it looks
like a fake
they make a cake look like a watermelon
they make an ice cream cake like a
watermelon on the outside
oh i know i'm talking about the only
time he eats fruit watermelon
[Laughter]
watermelon ice cream in the center it's
unbelievable in chocolate chips
[ __ ] a foley family favorite
they happen to thanksgiving the worst
was to get in the job to clean the corn
as a kid
they would hang like five brown bags of
corn and be i would always have facets
dude it'd be 120 degrees
sitting out there with your siblings
like shawshank redemption yeah
can you play some opera for me mom and
just like i remember they'd be like who
did this one and i like half-assed yeah
you know
getting called out on my [ __ ] work go to
the store get some niblets let's come on
keep it moving
are you guys a cream corn family you
ever do that no
yeah actually yes yep yeah love no way
that was one of those things like we
talked my mom we did on the patreon we
called our parents for the first episode
of the patreon we played with
our parents and my mom's like i she
wouldn't feed us anything that she
didn't like
so like i didn't have and she didn't
like beans so i didn't have beans until
i was like 31 years old
oh she's just like yeah we don't do it
now i [ __ ] love them yeah but
cream corn was one of those things it
was just like that it was never even
existed in my house i loved it
yeah i liked it too i loved cream corn
and the uh
and uh the potatoes with that put you
put them in cheese like
cotton or whatever yes oh come on great
thing yeah the best the the classiest
potato
is the twice baked potato do you know
that yeah
yeah yeah those are great yeah yeah does
your family make them we make them once
a year i think on thanksgiving
we used to do this
[Laughter]
a little paprika that's how trashy he is
he says the bread
he's like if you can find a spice in a
plastic container
let me tell you something you're at the
four seasons all right deviled eggs
without paprika with paprika huh
without paprika you know you just double
down
first of all you're adding syllables
yeah paprika
is there another egg in there it's
paprika yeah isn't it
oh she just [ __ ] stuck that somebody
comes through a little bit of money
oh my god he's even doing the trashy
english accent
cockney yeah we'll be in rubble body
trouble
rubble it wouldn't make sense if i did
the hybridist accent which i also can do
hit it nah i can't do it
but i love that you said deviled eggs
without paprika
is trash and then add deviled eggs
period is trash are they rosebuds yeah
i don't know enough about we never
deviled eggs is trash unless you're in
[ __ ]
london i think that's trash why london
i think they eat them for like tea you
don't know what the hell you're talking
about that and the ketchup you're just
smoke screening they definitely put
deviled eggs like on a sandwich
in london for high tea really yeah that
sounds pretty good
yeah i'm also saying this with
confidence yeah
i can see i see i see a
you know be pretty good is it doubled
egg on a blt double eggs on blt's
garbage cookbook it's coming it's
brewing i love it
deviled eggs london let's see maybe it
is
old favorites grams i don't know no
that's definitely an american garbage
thing
well they're garbage you're just saying
they're garbage no great though
i don't know
that's typically soft-boiled yes it is
whatever look at you extending your
palate past the
chicken face my lady likes more you're
more than applebee's you know what i
mean i gotta i'm googling a lot of stuff
at these restaurants we go to by the way
what the hell is a soft-boiled egg well
it's funny because she does there's some
things that she doesn't know language
like just language-wise yeah like what
is a deviled egg and i'm such a [ __ ]
daryl i'm like i don't so then i gotta
google it
right and they know i don't belong at
these places she likes to go to
yeah but it is what it is
uh i can see why you guys got married
she can't totally speak english
sure yeah yeah yeah she doesn't know
we're married technically
she just said yeah she's like roommates
that checks out we are just friends yeah
yeah um yeah okay
any good oh i'm sorry it wasn't bad fair
enough um all right this is kind of a
two-parter from two different people
this is how trashy
our listeners are great minds think
alike this is from eric babe real last
name sorry i'm ugly
all right that's his patreon name good
luck uh when all the plates are dirty
have you ever eaten a meal off something
that wasn't a plate
yeah like what is there a napkin oh
that's
that's all right yeah sorry you got
napkins on hand that's pretty good yeah
i mean
that's not the answer you can grab a
magazine
it was southern living better homes
[Laughter]
you're just dreaming about some
somewhere else to live
man if i could get my act together i
could live in this plantation house
you're like i've got a highlights around
here somewhere
from third grade l magazine yeah
um i've used you know the lid to a
chinese container
works perfectly as a as a plate yeah
also i've used i've used pizza boxes
for sure yeah but those are meant to be
plates but not
pizza what's in there that's fine like
i've like made something and then like
you just eaten off the top of the
like the pizza box was empty from the
night before or whatever
all right so the pizza box is like
sitting on the counter like ready to go
out to the trash
i don't think what are you doing makes
you trashy i think it just means you're
going through a hard time
it depends what it is it could be both i
don't i don't maybe i don't
even know i'm not eating like spaghetti
it's not spaghetti soup it's just
something you're like
i'm just sucking a cardboard box
you're taking bites out of it just
sucking all the moisture out and
throwing it over crackers
which isn't bad it's just something to
serve as like a crumb catcher kind
i would say if i'm making this up toast
yeah whatever i'm saying i'm eating
calling something that was garbage a
minute ago i will say calling your plate
a crumb catcher is
is garbage without a doubt
it's the best of all you've got some
catchers around here
that's what old guys say about their
beard yeah that's my soup taster
no they called their mouth a soup cooler
yeah a soup cooler that's yeah the old
soup cooler i think it's called
how old are you so much on the last
episode
because you're just filled with these
blue collar white trash sayings
some coolers baby you have a good time
on the podcast what do you want for me
we're having a fun time and then this
was also in the same way you said that i
didn't believe you you
[Laughter]
it's time to take it we're having a good
time
everything's cool
my parents the ultimate one of those to
me last night i called them
they were on their way somewhere and
they instantly got me off the phone like
i knew something was wrong
lily was like hey what's going on oh
we're just driving and all of a sudden
all right we'll talk to you later
literally literally in that vein and
they hung up
nothing in between nothing literally
that was it and i called him back and i
was like what's going on
my mom's like we're lost she didn't know
how to use the gps on her new iphone
no she just meant like personally still
trying to find yourself
she said they're driving they're just
sitting in the car
i don't know who i am anymore for the
second time she's whacked the antenna
off of the
explorer coming out of the uh garage
because she puts it in there because of
the snow
second time she's clipped it you saw it
yeah when we we went down to film we did
a cribs at his childhood home
yeah it's on the [ __ ] patreon and
his mom was leaving like when we got
there check out like leave us
and me and toby were out front like
doing like the shot of the
front of the house and she was backing
up and like ended up like four houses
down like
and the front yard hits the curb over
the curb the car's rattling his dad's
bopping his head around it was like a
[ __ ] scene
the thing i'm like i think we even got
it on camera i'm like yo she's about to
go off the curb
like toby just slowly panned and caught
it and she swears she does
she does it good but when i when i was
home last i looked up the sides of the
driveway where the grass are
there's like turf marks yeah it's all
mud and [ __ ] dude she pulls out of there
like she's pulling out of the hideout
or something she's disguised she's doing
a bank job that's how i drove when i was
drunk
never done that oh
yeah all right we've all parked in the
yard right
once or twice a new year's eve i don't
uh you know
i don't want to admit anything here but
one night of roses look good
i woke up at my mom like i was like
living in my i was in college or
whatever and like i woke up and i was
like all right and i'm like
[ __ ] i don't know how the you know yeah
well when you say i woke up at my mom's
like you didn't expect to be there
you lived in california it was weird um
i woke up
and i was like oh [ __ ] my car's not here
so i'm like i must have left it
i think it was new year's actually i was
like i must have left it at you know
[ __ ] steve's house whatever so
the living room i was like i'll just
walk to steve's house and i go up like i
walk out my street make a left and
another left and my car was there i'm
like oh god
i parked somewhere else in my
neighborhood and walked home for some
reason
oh my god stay off drugs folks yeah
don't do them kids stay in school uh the
other one from jacobs have you
ever used a bowl to drink out of because
you didn't have any clean glasses
i like it sometimes it's because you're
a cow i've also
i also cows don't even drink out of
bowls i don't know why i haven't but i
have done something way trashier
ugh lay it on ashtray you run out of
toilet paper and you use
uh coffee filters that's not bad coffee
filters
i'm not saying it feels good i'm not
saying i'm [ __ ] made a decision yeah
i'm using paper towels like an [ __ ]
no i got real creative but are they
flushable
they are no they are are they yes i mean
i've tried it
yeah no i mean we know they'll go down
the toilet but are they supposed to be
flushable
no okay i mean is toilet paper supposed
to be
what are you doing yeah what do you do
with the coffee we're gonna play games
i mean that's not i mean
a coffee filter that's smart and also
who's got coffee filters in the house
that's pretty pretty good
well i told you we were a camping family
for one or two
resourceful uh i i'm sure it was
probably number two because that's when
you get creative like that you know what
i mean
number two you got it you go if you're
hemmed up with a one you can make do
yeah you use a sock i've heard people
doing that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i feel like i've had to [ __ ] in the
woods a couple of times
i had to [ __ ] in the woods a couple of
times
i got a toothpick that's another one of
yours [ __ ]
in the woods the one thing toby zoom in
that's one of these new things yeah i
[ __ ] in the woods once or twice
whatever no but you take your shoe off
you put your hand
and you can like you can get a little
scoop actually oh i never thought to do
it like take the socks throw it in the
[ __ ] bushes
that's brutal hey mrs
it's not a [ __ ] ice cream bar have
you ever pooped in the woods
yeah pooping without the you don't
realize
the buffer that that water gives in the
bowl a smell
oh yeah brutal that's the whole point of
the water you know that right i didn't
know that yeah the whole point of the
water is to keep
the sun was to get it out of the house
no to keep the smell because the smell
can't come there's not water under that
the water only sits in the bottom of the
toilet yeah right but if there wasn't
water
it would just sit there yeah but the
smell from the whole sewage system
the water stops the smell from the
sewage system yeah the p trap
oh wow we're learning things yeah
family of plumbers shout out to local 69
[Laughter]
don't cross the line if you do you're a
[ __ ] rat
[ __ ] scam you think i won't [ __ ] in
the woods you think i won't [ __ ] in the
woods
does a kippy [ __ ] in the woods this has
been a wacky episode folks yeah there's
a kippy [ __ ] in the woods
um all right let's see this is from joe
have you ever taken a hair out of your
food
at a restaurant and kept eating the meal
yeah but that was just to be agreeable
yeah to who to just not cause a scene
not to be
exactly what people think i am
yeah you have can you send this back
face yeah sure yeah i want the
restaurant i'm like
tomorrow i'm gonna break down
stereotypes today and just just eat this
hair yeah
i get it um it's funny you mentioned
that recently
like this week uh i was at home
and my girlfriend had prepared something
and one of her hairs was in there
boobs sprinkled them all
a little garnish with the paprika
sprinkle them on like food
uh one of her hairs was definitely in it
and i just kept eating it
yeah it's right here yeah it's fine yeah
that's fine it is what it is
it's somebody else's sure you guys have
exchanged dna before it's not
uh it's true um all right this is from
michael uh this is from michael
uh this is just funny did your doorbell
ever not work for longer than a
six-month period
oh yeah really my doorbell everywhere
until recently get up to that house you
press the button it just goes too far
you can feel there's no resistance
behind it like what the [ __ ] is this
i remember our doorbell broke and my mom
never fixed it she just never
she just put um uh christmas decorations
on the doorbell so that
like are on the door handle so when you
opened it a bunch of like jingles
reindeer jingles
that's pretty good made sneaking out
impossible sounds like a general store
yeah exactly you know when someone you
walk in how are you doing folks
it's like you're in a western you can
make an announcement that's
like old man rivers is [ __ ]
shot up the bar down the way drunk again
she's down in the well yeah
i'm all right
rosebud stole the mayor's car again
we gotta get downtown i was waiting for
you to chime in with your prospector
voice
you've been [ __ ] workshopping for a
month now
that was a pretty good one
how many doorbells did you have we had
two [ __ ] two yeah we had two
doorbells we had like
what do you mean we had the small one on
the dishwasher
we had a small one a small and then like
a bigger one
did you have two entrances what's wrong
no they were at the same entrance the
one was like the intercom system i guess
when regular bozos came around you had
an intercom system
that's classy i'm surprised you didn't i
would expect you too
well it depends on that we talked about
yeah this is why i'm pointing i'm
jealous you could see that yeah she was
like
you had an inner cold one second
no um in the 80s my parents had some
cash
and they got a house built and that was
like state-of-the-art technology for
like a week
right was like oh you'll be able to
intercom each room or whatever okay
the rest of it it also went to the
neighbors
like that our back deck you could talk
to the neighbor's front deck kind of it
was like a cul-de-sac and everybody's
supposed to know each other's supposed
to be like a little like
you guys had walkie-talkies installed in
your house ultimately is what it was
with a cassette player yeah how weird is
that
that is [ __ ] weird you gotta see the
console that's very weird it's real it's
hidden
it's like you don't see it because like
the the one door covers it all the time
but it's trash it's like wooden that is
the weirdest such
it was cool it was it was hot for
probably a weekend in the 80s
and they were like let's put them in
this house and it just it's the truth
probably because of the cold war
you wanted to be able to coordinate it's
like people people interested in
russians that's what i was going to say
i was like this feels like some
government interference [ __ ]
where they sell you something and then
you buy it and then you go oh wait we
have phones
yeah it was similar yeah i don't we
never used it i don't even know if it
ever fully worked some kind of early
warning system yeah
mm-hmm i don't know well they never got
us so cops coming down the street
burn it burn it who knew what my dad was
doing
jenny if his son's over there tell them
to get underneath the covers
kippy shits in the woods
[Laughter]
send their that's like that's that's the
flipping pigeons of a cul-de-sac
is get on the intercon system to the
neighbors absolutely
heat's coming around the corner all
right let's do it two doorbells
yeah we had the big one and then the
little that doesn't even make so we had
like the ding-dong
and then we had the like
like the longer song if you wanted to be
classical
that's crazy i don't know the classical
doorbells are definitely trash i think
the songs doorbells in general stink
you knock get a knocker knockers are
classy yeah you knock
doorbells are for big houses though true
you know you can't you can't hear a
knock from the west wing
growing up over the screams of the maid
you know what i mean oh that's another
this isn't even this isn't a patreon but
at any point
in any of the houses you had the vacuum
system in the wall
yes really we did have that did we have
to we didn't talk absolutely had that we
definitely had
that was my neighbor had that that was
the best something else
so he just put the tube in the wall yeah
and
if you have little siblings you tell
them to put their ear up against it all
of a sudden they're screaming for
[ __ ] life here yeah what the [ __ ] is
a lot of fun
you put a cheek up or something yeah or
your wee way in there
yeah that's the real my mom had ours
taken out when i hit puberty
she had a decommissioned
[Laughter]
well mrs ryan don't know how to tell you
this but uh i'm eating it out
you got two pounds of cumin
system
you're all clogged up we've seen this
all over the neighborhood you're just
sitting on the couch with a big smile on
your face
does it get becoming the vacuum you got
yourself a classic
class of 2002 in here
i was so jealous of that man my one
buddy's mom had it it was the richest
thing i'd ever seen in my life
yeah unbelievable what else is big do
you have a laundry shoot
no what a laundry shoot laundry shoot is
old money
yeah would you have a dumb waiter too no
a lot of people
yeah a lot of people not a lot of people
but they were relatively common i would
say they were probably
as common as the vacuum in the [ __ ]
house no
they were yeah laundry shoot yeah cause
they were like uh
it's like old houses you know what i
mean if you bought like an old house
with old money
you had a laundry shoe a dumb waiter and
that and that like vacuum system
that place is definitely on it for sure
i had a good amount
it comes with victorian ghosts but
good day my lad for shut out please
um i had some pretty rich friends
growing up
and none of them ever had a lot of them
had the [ __ ] vacuum in the wall
nobody had a [ __ ] laundry shoot i
know we would have been diving down
every three seconds yeah yeah i think my
neighbor might i don't know
laundry yeah that or did you have uh dog
doors were trashy
i always thought they were we never had
dog doors my buddy had though and we
always had dogs no dogs
you have a dog no dog yeah my buddy had
him we always used to break into his
house to get stuff
i don't honestly i don't understand it i
don't trust it bugs that anything could
fall
you don't trust it cause you can't fit
through it that's just fully
stuck in there what kind of dog is this
no i wouldn't want i wouldn't feel i
would be able to sleep at night no
just that thing got to the outside if
you do have a dog door though and this
is just
for devil's advocate if you have a dog
door that means you trust your neighbors
enough
to feel like you're never going to get
robbed sure well yeah we were in a
you're you got to have it
you can't be doing it in [ __ ] you
know bed-stuy brooklyn right you can't
have a dog door right
should be coming in yeah it's gonna be a
nice neighborhood yeah
so i think door doors probably are a
little classy i don't know
you gotta be cla it's a trashy decision
from a classy home
hmm i don't hate that that's pretty good
yeah rosebuds had a couple
couple of [ __ ] perspective changers
we're used to like real trash
she can walk in both worlds you know
what i mean yeah real poignant
yeah i'm a real uh shapeshifter
all right this is from charlie have you
ever rented movies talking about
politics you steal the smokes out of
your pocket
uh this is from charlie have you ever
rented movies from the library
what library any library you mean where
the books are
that's what i think he means who the
[ __ ] renting movies i
i never have they have they have i
highly doubt rosebud ever has
no yeah yeah i think you can go rent
like movies
what yeah t-bone shaking his head yeah
really oh my god what are you doing a
lot
like [ __ ] the bridge over the river
quiet yeah i feel like it's gotta be
like
some like ballet yeah they don't have
new releases i know that much you
weren't watching encino man or space jam
i could tell you that much
you're watching somebody's kid's dance
recital
[Laughter]
t-bone t-bone can't defend himself i
know i heard you got a small wee-wee too
t-bone
no i never did that i missed the library
though can i say that
for as much as as little as i've read
you know they've been open this whole
[ __ ] time
i know but you know i love that they
left the libraries open during covet
because they were just like yeah nobody
we only get two people we get two people
a month anyway we're under we're under
the limitations
we live in quarantine the idea of a
library back in the day was nice
yeah well the idea of it is still nice
but going there is a different thing
some riff-raff i never got the dewey
decimal system either i could never say
framer yeah what yeah that's a creamer
line is it a dewy decimal system
definitely an 80s bit i'll tell you that
i was being genuine
what's with the dewey decimal system i
never understood it i was being genuine
okay i'm sorry i was making it what's
with reagan we're very sorry
all right i mean what's going on there
we go what an [ __ ]
um this is mike dukakis
folks we're having a good time all right
let's do two i meant that genuinely
okay yeah it's fine um this is from doug
have you ever given a receiving a hickey
bonus points if
your mom or dad tried to kill you for a
hat like did you ever have one at a bad
time i'm sure you've had one at some
point
oh yeah did you ever have one where it
was like an embarrassment
i mean i've had one in the last year oh
a hickey
yeah why she's a who win
[Laughter]
i was hooking up with an old guy well it
wasn't the last year it was last two
years well yeah you just gotta
i just got married oh yeah just really
just fudged up your timeline there
but my husband's not exactly you know a
spring chicken
good looking kid though good looking
tight body yeah he's got a swimmer's
body yeah he got phil
he actually has like a like a 1930s
boxer body
you know what i mean that's a good look
looks like he looks like a butler in the
30s he's got like a broad chest and it
looks like he can like move a hay bale
yeah
i mean like a year or two after the
depression where he's putting on a
little bit of weight yeah i mean
yeah exactly i can see it yeah if he
could grow a mustache man let me tell
you it would be a hint it would be like
the like
absolutely it would be a little he could
be old-timey yeah yeah we could he's got
that hairline too
yeah it's good it's good stuff um i only
had a hickey once or twice
i didn't really see much in it i've seen
people with them [ __ ] i've got i've
gotten them bad as
adults to where i had to like i've
always got i've gotten like two
ads of as an adult who gave you a hickey
not my
why i mean it was before you know that
is yeah in my 20s so funny when
married people have to remember like
their past
hookups they get they get this weird
like like
an adult and i started thinking of like
well how old am i well i'm technically
an adult when i'm 23 or 24 okay
i thought you were 29 or 32.
yeah um but i had one like i've gotten
them i had one at thanksgiving
uh-huh the night before thanksgiving the
big party night you know
yeah i've had one of thanksgiving see
the people from high school you hook up
with that yeah and you're like wearing a
turtleneck or like
you know and you're like there's no way
around it you're trying to put the spoon
you show up for dinner you're like i
always wear a turtleneck and a vest
what yeah that's that's who i am it's my
new thing that and chris
at our family christmas party and my
family shoes so we have our christmas
parties like 200 people
yeah and like like had like my collar
popped or something everybody's like
right away like ripped what's that oh my
god yeah it's embarrassing i thought you
got the hickey there
am i for you shout out to uncle john
i'm telling you they keep that mistletoe
roll pretty strict
don't walk under there when uncle mitch
is around
he'll get you okay i don't i don't hate
it
uncle mitch yeah if you got an uncle
mitch
he's on a list um
that and randy ah this is from mark b
this will be the last one
uh anyone in your family have vanity
license plates
oh yeah really yeah my mom
what six chicks
that was our vanity plate well you have
five sisters five
five girls and then my mom six chicks
six chicks shedded on a big red suburban
that's not that bad it's not no six
chicks
it ain't good it's not that bad
no vanity plate is great that's the the
fact that you're trying
yeah they're not it's not cool you know
anything it's one step above a bumper
sticker it's a legal bumper sticker is
what it's a government-issued bumper
sticker yeah
it is yeah however there is some degree
to it like that's a little bit
i think it's based on family so i kind
of get it you're not doing like number
one birds fan or something
the worst ones are the ones where
they're trying to be a jerk off you know
like your girls next or something like
that you know what i mean
never saw that your girl's neck i'm not
saying it right when it's jesus
sure where it's a shot at yeah yeah yeah
somebody's like run the plates let's see
if there's a background on this guy
they're like oh he's got a vanity plate
that says your girl's next
never mind we don't need to check
anymore yeah sorry this might be the
killer clearly
he's clearly got a couple bodies in the
trunk he's that apparently he's having
sex with my wife right now
or he's on his way there i'm not sure
either way i'm glad i intercepted the
man
yeah do you remember those things in the
the sayings on the front of the car and
the on the windshield
at the top that's where i got that from
but i was trying to use that i was like
in the day they would put lettering at
the top or like the the
yeah oh yeah yeah or the shade or like
the tint is
it's always on the back of a pickup
pickup was real big and i never forget i
never knew what this was until i found
out later
we were down the shore and see well
that's how things work out
you're gonna be a stickler right now
you're gonna start breaking my [ __ ]
balls
rosebud um i never knew what this was
until somebody told me
no but it took me i didn't it stuck in
my head and we were walking down and
there was a jetta uh
and it said ron jeremy on the back of it
and i never knew what ron jeremy was but
all my older cousins were laughing like
yo do you [ __ ] see that because they
were like teenagers yeah
you know so i was like and it stuck in
my head and i was like somebody so
[ __ ] whack i was driving around with
ron jeremy on the back of their car
in big yellow letters that's insane are
you not following what i'm saying
no we're following it but you didn't
know who he was
i didn't know who ron jeremy was i
thought that was like a skate company or
something like that
he's a porn star no i know but isn't it
ron john
first of all he's a director and an
artist
and apparently a bit of a rapist
i think he's got a lot of titles i might
be thinking of a different sticker that
says ron something almost in like
chinese language
ron johnson no i'm saying somebody had
ron jeremy's name on their car in big
yellow letters
as a kid i feel like you're not giving
me what i what i'm looking for
well nobody knows what to say they're
just going oh you found out who ron
jeremy was
i would also i would also like an
appreciation of yeah it's pretty crazy
somebody was driving around with a porn
star's name
on their jetta it's the 80s it's kind of
it's it is a little
it's a lot that's there we go there we
go that's what i was looking for yeah
somehow it's less annoying than the
honor roll [ __ ] though what did you
think
the honor roll my kid's an honor roll
yeah your kid's a douchebag
comes around my parts yeah right down to
hit the bricks yeah
around around our area you see a lot of
the peewee football things
like the pee wee football logos like on
the back of people's trucks yeah
a lot of trump 2020 signs too yeah yeah
that's hit
those deads hit yeah all right well that
was it
weird one more all right we'll do one
more uh
that one really ran out gas jeremy's
story well you were like sitting there
like i was giving a [ __ ] deposition
like i don't know but just i
said sticking movement you set it up
didn't he set it up like it was gonna be
a longer story
so what did you think ron jeremy was i
didn't know
i just thought it was like a car
manufacturer or something and then i was
doing a little google search on jeremy
as i got older
and found out that he's a porn star with
a huge hog
you're like just one car multiple cars
one car you're looking at
you're looking at like porn later on in
life yeah i'm like here's the toyota
dealer this is the guy
yeah that's all his jetta down the shore
so [ __ ] talented yeah maybe it was
really wrong
this guy's giving away cars
um all right we got two from uh we'll do
two from the fa or we'll do one from the
facebook
group this is from rich is it garbage to
cut your fingernails with scissors
what the [ __ ] so yeah what's a i mean
what's a [ __ ] fingernail clipper
i'll tell you why it's garbage how
[ __ ] long are your fingernails
that you can get under there yeah yeah
maybe the okay i've seen
little scissors that have a little hook
on them that are four
i think that's not for that i don't
think i think it is
isn't it thank you yeah cuticles but
it's not for you right your fingernails
that's for cuticle how do you [ __ ]
cut your cuticles with scissors
i wouldn't do it oh my skin just my
blood just ran cold i don't even like to
snip them because they feel weird i like
to bite them oh you looks like you're a
couple that's garbage
yeah jesus christ
[Laughter]
gang that is the show this week you guys
are absolutely fantastic thank you
rosebud thank you for sitting with us
thank you what do you got uh you got uh
zany's nashville march 14th
yeah yeah i'm gonna be recording that
album there's tickets are available on
my website rosebudbaker.com and on
zany's website
uh which is you just look up nashville
zanies and um
and then my podcast find your beach with
my hubs andy haynes
there you go we love it thank you buddy
great great [ __ ] episode
a lot of great times what do you got for
me uh at kevrant comedy on all social
media and then you know rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and then patreon.com you can
sign up get involved cards are going out
this week baby they're going out we love
you guys thank you for all the support
this month it's been a it's been a great
month and we appreciate it it's good to
be back here at today's
nice to be back at toodies yeah i can
smell the new ports t-bone you got
anything
hey
it's great to see you buddy we love you
it's great it's great to be back here
we'll see you guys next week bye hold on
there kids don't go
and ship just yet i want to talk to you
one more time
about the good times over there on the
stereo app gang here's the good news
doesn't matter whether you have an
iphone or an
android you can download the app you can
sign up for free
yeah guys it's a great app there's a lot
of good stuff on there we're on there
every week answering your garbage
questions
it's a great way to get involved with
the show we chop it up i have a couple
of beers i know that much
okay there's a couple of pops over there
hair come down it's a good time i look
forward to it every week you can sign up
the link use the link in the description
of the app
we get to what our beaks you guys get
involved it's a good time
see you there peace